The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So today we're going to continue
on with some of the
design patterns that we started
talking about last week.
So to recap, there are really
four common steps to taking a
program and then parallelizing
it.
Often you're starting off with
a program that's designed or
written in a sequential
manner.
And what you want to do is find
tasks in the program --
and these are sort of
independent work pieces that
you are going to be able
to decompose from
your sequential code.
You're going to group
tasks together
into threads or processes.
And then you'll essentially map
each one of these threads
or processes down to the
actual hardware.
And that will get you,
eventually when these programs
run, the concurrency
and the performance
speedups that you want.
So as a reminder of what I
talked about last week in
terms of finding the task or
finding the concurrency, you
start off with an application.
You come up with a block
level diagram.
And from that you sort of try
to understand where the time
is spent in the computations
and what are some typical
patterns for how the
computations are carried out.
So we talked about task
decomposition or sort of
independent tasks or tasks that
might be different that
the application is
carrying out.
So in the MPEG encoder, we
looked at decoding the motion
vectors for temporal compression
versus spatial
compression.
It does sort of substantially
different work.
We talked about data
decomposition.
So if you're doing a process
-- so if you have some work
that's really consuming a large
chunk of data, and you
realize that it's applying the
same kind of work to each of
those data pieces, then you can
partition your data into
smaller subsets and apply
the same function
over and over again.
So in the motion compensation
phase, that's one example
where you can replicate the
function and split up the data
stream in different ways
and have these
tasks proceed in parallel.
So that's data decomposition.
And then we talked a little
bit about sort of making a
case for a pipeline
decomposition.
So you have a data assembly
line or producer-consumer
chains, and you essentially
want to recognize those in
your computation and make it so
that you can exploit them
eventually when you're
doing your mapping
down to actual hardware.
But what does it mean for
two tasks to actually be
concurrent?
And how do you know that you
can safely actually run two
tasks in parallel?
So there's something I crudely
went over last time.
So as to make it more concrete,
highlighting
Bernstein's condition, which
says that given two tasks, if
the input set to one task is
different from or does not
intersect with the output set
of another, and vice versa,
and neither task sort of
updates the same data
structures in memory, then
there's really no dependency
issues between them.
You can run them safely
in parallel.
So task T1 and T2, if all the
data that's consumed by T1, so
all the data elements that are
read by T1 are different from
the ones that are read by
T2, then you have --
you know, if T2 is running in
parallel, there's really no
problem with T1 because
it's updating the
orthogonal data set.
Similarly for T2 and T1, any
outputs are different.
So as an example, let's say
you have two tasks.
In T1 you're doing some
basic statements.
And these could be essentially
more coarse grained.
There could be a lot more
computation in here.
I just simplified it for
the illustration.
So you have task a
equals x plus y.
And task two does b
equals x plus z.
So if we look at the read set
for T1, these are all the
variables or data structures
or addresses these that are
read by the first task.
So that's x and y here.
And all the data that's written
or produced by T1.
So here we're just producing
one data value.
And that's going into
location A.
Similarly we can come up
with the read set and
write set for T2.
And so that's shown on here.
So we have -- task T2 has x
plus z in its read set.
And it produces one
data value, b.
If we take the intersection of
the read and write sets for
the different tasks,
then they're empty.
I read something completely
different than what's produced
in this task and vice versa.
And they write to
two completely
different memory locations.
So I can essentially parallelize
these or run these
two tasks in parallel.
So you can extend
this analysis.
And compilers can actually use
this condition to determine
when two tasks can be
parallelized if you're doing
automatic parallelization.
And you'll probably hear more
about these later on.
And so what I focused on last
time were the finding
concurrency patterns.
And I had identified sort of
four design spaces based on
the work that's outlined in the
book by Mattson, Sanders,
and Massingill.
And so starting with two
large sort of concepts.
The first helps you figure out
how you're going to actually
express your algorithm.
So first you find your
concurrency and then you
organize in some way.
And so we're going to talk about
that in more detail.
And then once you've organized
your tasks in some way that
actually expresses your overall
computation, you need
some software construction
utilities or data structures
or mechanisms for actually
orchestrating computations for
which they have also abstracted
out some common patterns.
And so I'll briefly talk
about these as well.
And so on your algorithm
expression side, these are
essentially conceptualization
steps that help you abstract
out your problem.
And you may in fact think
about your algorithm
expression in different ways to
expose different kinds of
concurrency or to be able to
explore different ways of
mapping the concurrency
to hardware.
And so for construction it's
more about actual engineering
and implementation.
So here you're actually thinking
about what do the
data structures look like?
What is the communication
pattern going to look like?
Am I but going to use things
like MPI or OpenMP?
What does that help me with
in terms of doing my
implementation?
So given a collection of
concurrent tasks -- so you've
done your first step in your
four design patterns.
You know, what is
your next step?
And that's really mapping
those tasks that you've
identified down to some sort
of execution units.
So threads are very common.
This is essentially what we've
been using on Cell.
We take our computation and we
wrap it into SPE threads and
then we can execute
those at run time.
So some things to keep in mind
-- although you shouldn't over
constrain yourself in terms
of these considerations.
What is the magnitude of
your parallelism that
you're going to get?
You know, do you want hundreds
or thousands of threads?
Or do you want something
on the order of tens?
And this is because you don't
want to overwhelm the intended
system that you're
going to run on.
So we talked about yesterday on
Cell processor, if you're
creating a lot more than six
threads, then you can create
problems or you essentially
don't get extra parallelism
because each thread is running
to completion on each SPE.
And contact switch overhead
is extremely high.
So you don't want to spend too
much engineering cost to come
up with an algorithm
implementation that's
massively scalable to hundreds
or thousands of threads when
you can't actually exploit it.
But that doesn't mean that you
should over constrain your
implementation to where if now
I want to take your code and
run it on a different machine, I
essentially have to redesign
or re-engineer the
complete process.
So you want to avoid tendencies
to over constrain
the implementation.
And you want to leave your code
in a way that's malleable
so that you can easily make
changes to sort of factor in
new platforms that you want
to run on or new machine
architecture features that you
might want to exploit.
So there are three major
organization principles I'm
going to talk about.
And none of these should be sort
of foreign to you at this
point because we've talked about
them in different ways
in the recitations or in
previous lectures.
And it's really, what is it that
determines sort of the
algorithm structure based on the
set of tasks that you're
actually carrying out
in your computation?
And so there's the principle
that says,
organize things by tasks.
I'm going to talk to that.
And then there's a principle
that says, well, organize
things by how you're doing
the data decomposition.
So in this case how you're
actually distributing the data
or how to the data is laid out
in memory, or how you're
partitioning the data to
actually compute on it
dictates how you should actually
organize your actual
computation.
And then there's organize
by flow of data.
And this is something you'll
hear about more in the next
lecture where we're talking
about streaming.
But in this pattern if there
are specific sort of
computations that take advantage
of high bandwidth
flow of data between
computations, you might want
to exploit that for
concurrency.
And we'll talk about
that as well.
OK.
So a design diagram
for how can you
actually go through process.
So you can ask yourself
a set of questions.
if I want to organize things
by tasks, then there are
essentially two main clusters or
two main computations, two
main patterns.
If the code is recursive, then
you essentially want to apply
a divide and conquer pattern
or divide and conquer
organization.
If it's not recursive.
then you essentially want
to do task parallelism.
So in task parallelism --
you know, I've listed
two examples here.
But really any of the things
that we've talked
about in the past fit.
Ray computation, ray tracing.
So here you're shooting rays
through a scene to try to
determine how to render it.
And really each ray is a
separate and independent
computation step.
In molecular dynamics you're
trying to determine the
non-bonded force calculations.
There are some dependencies,
but really you can do each
calculation for one molecule
or for one atom
independent of any other.
And then there are sort of the
global dependence of having to
update or communicate across all
those molecules that sort
of reflect new positions
in the system.
So the common factors here are
your tasks are associated with
iterations of a loop.
And you can distribute, you
know, each process --
each processor can
do a different
iteration of the loop.
And often you know sort of what
the tasks are before you
actually start your
computation.
Although in some cases, like
in ray tracing, you might
generate more and more threads
as you go along, or more and
more computations because as
the ray is shooting off,
you're calculating
new reflections.
And that creates sort
of extra work.
But largely you have these
independent tasks that you can
encapsulate in threads
and you run them.
And this is sort of -- it might
appear subtle, but there
are algorithm classes where not
all tasks essentially need
to complete for you to
arrive at a solution.
You know, in some cases
you might convert to
an acceptable solution.
And you don't actually need to
go through and exercise all
the computation that's
outstanding for you to say the
program is done.
So there will be a
tricky issue --
I'll revisit this just briefly
later on -- is how do you
determine if your program
has actually
terminated or has completed?
In divide and conquer, this is
really for recursive programs.
You know, you can think of a
well-known sorting algorithm,
merge sort, that classically
fits into this kind of
picture, where you have some
really large array of data
that you want to sort.
You keep subdividing into
smaller and smaller chunks
until you can do local
reorderings.
And then you start merging
things together.
So this gives you sort of a way
to take a problem, divide
it into subproblems. And then
you can split the data at some
point and then you join
it back together.
You merge it.
You might see things like fork
and merge or fork and join
used instead of split
and join.
I've used the terminology that
sort of melds well with some
of the concepts we use in
streaming that you'll see in
the next lecture.
And so in these kinds of
programs, it's not always the
case that each subproblem will
have essentially the same
amount of work to do.
You might need more dynamic load
balancing because each
subproblem --
how you distribute the data
might lead you to do more work
in one problem than
in the other.
So as opposed to some of the
other mechanisms where static
load balancing will work
really well --
and to remind you, static load
balancing essentially says,
you have some work, you assign
it to each of the processors.
And you're going to be
relatively happy with how each
processor's sort of
utilization is
going to be over time.
Nobody's going to be too
overwhelmed with the amount of
work they have to do.
In this case, you might end up
with needing some things for
dynamic load balancing that
says, I'm unhappy with the
work performance
or utilization.
Some processors are more idle
than the others, so you might
want to essentially redistribute
things.
So what we'll talk about --
you know, how does this
concept of divide and conquer
parallelization pattern work
into the actual implementation?
You know, how do I actually
implement a divide and conquer
organization?
The next organization is
organized by data.
So here you have some
computation --
not sure why it's flickering.
AUDIENCE: Check your --
maybe your VGA cables
aren't in good.
PROFESSOR: So in the organize by
data, you essentially want
to apply this if you have a
lot of computation that's
using a shared global data
structure or that's going to
update a central
data structure.
So in molecular dynamics, for
example, you have a huge array
that records the position of
each of the molecules.
And while you can do the
coarse calculations
independently, eventually all
the parallel tasks have to
communicate with the central
data structure and say, here
are the new locations for
all the molecules.
And so that has to go into
a central repository.
And there are different kinds
of sort of decompositions
within this organization.
If your data structure is
recursive, so a link list or a
tree or a graph, then
you can apply the
recursive data pattern.
If it's not, if it's linear,
like an array or a vector,
then you apply geometric
decomposition.
And you've essentially seen
geometric decomposition.
These were some of the labs
that you've already done.
And so the example from
yesterday's recitation, you're
doing an end body simulation in
terms of who is gravitating
towards who, you're calculating
the forces between
pairs of objects.
And depending on the force that
each object feels, you
calculate a new motion vector.
And you use that to update the
position of each body in your,
say, galaxy that you're
simulating.
And so what we talked about
yesterday was given an array
of positions, each processor
gets a sub-chunk of that
position array.
And it knows how to
calculate sort of
locally, based on that.
And then you might also
communicate local chunks to do
more scalable computations.
And recursive data structure are
a little bit more tricky.
So at face value you might think
that there's really no
kind of parallelism you
can get out of a
recursive data structure.
So if you're iterating over a
list and you want to get the
sum, well, you know, I just need
to go through the list.
Can I really parallelize that?
There are, however,
opportunities where you can
reshape the computation in
a way that exposes the
concurrency.
And often what this comes down
to is you're going to do more
work, but it's OK because you're
going to finish faster.
So this kind of work/concurrency
tradeoff, I'm
going to illustrate
with an example.
So in this application
we have some graphs.
And for each node in
a graph, we want to
know what is its root?
So this works well when you have
a forest where not all
the graphs are connected and
given a node you want to know
who is the root of this graph.
So what we can do is essentially
have more
concurrency by changing the way
we actually think about
the algorithm.
So rather than starting with
each node and then, in a
directed graph, following
its successor --
so this is essentially order
n, because for each node we
have to follow n links --
we can think about it slightly
differently.
So what if rather than finding
the successor and then finding
that successor's successor, at
each computational step we
start with a node and
we say who is
your successor's successor?
So we can converge in this
example in three steps.
So from five to six we can say
who is this successor?
So who is the successor's
successor of five?
And that would be two.
And similarly you can do that
for seven and so on.
And so you keep asking
the question.
So you can distribute all
these data structures,
repeatedly ask these questions
out of all these end nodes,
and it leads you to an order log
n solution versus an order
n solution.
But what have I done
in each step?
Well, I've actually created
myself and I've sort of
increased the amount of work
that I'm doing by order n.
Right there.
Right.
Yes.
Because I've essentially for
each node doing n queries, you
know, who's your successor's
successor?
Whereas in a sequential case,
you know, I just need to do it
once for each node.
And that works really well.
So most strategies based on
this pattern of actually
decomposing your computation
according to recursive pattern
lead you to doing much more work
or some increase in the
amount of work.
But you get this back
in because you can
decrease your execution.
And so this is a good
tradeoff that you
might want to consider.
AUDIENCE: In the first one
order n was sequential?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
It's a typo.
Yeah.
So organize by flow or organize
by flow of data.
And this is essentially
the pipeline model.
And we talked about this again
in some of the recitations in
terms of SPE to SPE
communication.
Or do you want to organize
based on event-based
mechanisms?
So what these really come down
to is, well, how regular is
the flow of data in
your application?
If you have regular, let's say,
one-way flow through a
stable computation path --
so I've set up my sort of
algorithm structure.
Data is flowing through
it at a regular rate.
The computation graph isn't
changing very much.
Then I can essentially pipeline
things really well.
And this could be a linear chain
of computation or it
could be sort of nonlinear.
There could be branches
in the graph.
And I can use that in a way to
exploit pipeline parallelism.
If I don't have sort of this
nice, regular structure, it
could be events that are
created at run time.
So, for example, you're a
car wash attendant and a
new car comes in.
So you have to find a garage to
assign to it and then turn
on the car wash machine.
So the dynamic threads are
created based on sensory input
that comes in, then you might
want to use an events-based
coordination.
You have irregular
computation.
The computation might vary based
on the data that comes
into your system.
And you might have unpredictable
data flow.
So in the pipeline model, the
things to consider is the
pipeline throughput versus
the pipeline latency.
So the amount of concurrency
in a pipeline is really
limited by the number
of stages.
This is nothing new.
You've seen this, for example,
in super scaled pipelines.
And just as in this case, as in
the case of an architecture
pipeline, the amount of time
it takes you to fill the
pipeline and the amount of time
it takes you to drain the
pipeline can essentially
limit your parallelism.
So you want those to be really
small compared to the actual
computation that you spend
in your pipeline.
And the performance metric is
usually the throughput.
How much data can you
pump through your
pipeline per unit time?
So in video encoding, you know,
it's the frames per
second that you can produce.
And the pipeline latency,
though, is important,
especially in a real-time
application where you need a
result every 10 milliseconds.
You know, your pacemaker for
example has to produce a beep
or a signal to your heart
at specific rates.
So you need to consider what
is your pipeline throughput
versus your pipeline latency?
And that can actually determine
how many stages you
might want to actually decompose
or organize your
application in.
And in the event-based
coordination, these are
interactions of tasks over
unpredictable intervals.
And you're more prone to sort
of deadlocks in these
applications.
Because you might have cyclic
dependencies where one event
can't proceed until it gets
data from another event.
But it can't proceed until it
gets data from another event.
You can create sort of these
complex interactions that
often lead to deadlock.
So you have to sort of be very
careful in structuring things
together so you don't end up
with feedback loops that block
computation progress.
So given sort of these three
organizational structures that
say, you know, I can organize
my computation by task or by
the flow of data or by sort of
the pipeline nature of the
computation, what are the
supporting structures?
How do I actually
implement these?
And so there are many
different supporting
structures.
I've identified sort of four
that occur most often in
literature and in
books and common
terminology that's used.
And so those are SPMD, loop
parallelism, the master/worker
pattern, and the fork/join
pattern.
In the SPMD pattern, you're
talking about a single
program, multiple
data concept.
So here you just have
one program.
You write it once and then you
assign it to each of your
processors to run.
So it's the same program.
It just runs on different
machines.
Now each program or each
instance of the code can have
different control flow
that it takes.
So just because they're running
the same program
doesn't mean the computation
is happening in lock step.
That would be a sort of a SIMD
or vector-like computation.
In this model you can actually
take independent control flow.
It could be different behavior
in each instance of the code.
But you're running the
same code everywhere.
So this is slightly different,
for example, from what you've
seen on Cell, where you have
the PPE thread that creates
SPE threads.
Sometimes the SPE threads are
the same, but it's not always
the case that the PPE
threads and the SPE
threads are the same.
So in the SPMD model there are
really five steps that you do.
You initialize sort of your
computation in the world of
sort of code instances that
you're going to run.
And for each one you obtain
a unique identifier.
And this usually helps them
being able to determine who
needs to communicate with who
or ordering dependencies.
And you run the same program
on each processor.
And what you need to do in this
case is also distribute
your data between each
of the different
instances of your code.
And once, you know, each program
is running, it's
computing on its data,
eventually you need to
finalize in some way.
And so that might mean doing a
reduction to communicate all
the data to one processor to
actually output the value.
And so we saw in SPMD an example
for the numerical
integration for calculating
pi.
And if you remember, so we had
this very simple c loop.
And we showed the MPI
implementation of the c loop.
And so in this code, what we're
doing is we're trying to
determine different intervals.
And for each interval we're
going to calculate a value and
then in the MPI program we're
essentially deciding how big
an interval each process
should run.
So it's the same program.
It runs on every single
machine or
every single processor.
And each processor determines
based on its ID which interval
of the actual integration
to do.
And so in this model
we're distributing
work relatively evenly.
Each processor is doing a
specific chunk that starts at
say some index i.
And if I have 10 processors,
I'm doing 100 steps.
Then you're doing i, i plus
10, i plus 20 and so on.
But I can do a different
distribution.
So the first is a block
I can do something called
a cyclic distribution.
So in a cyclic distribution, I
distribute work sort of in a
round robin fashion or
some other mechanism.
So here, you know,
each processor --
sorry.
In the block distribution I sort
of start at interval i
and I go --
sorry.
So each processor gets one
entire slice here.
So I start here and I go
through to completion.
I start here and go through
to completion.
In a cyclic distribution I might
do smaller slices of
each one of those intervals.
And so I greyed out the
components for the block
distribution to show you that
for a contrast here.
There are some challenges
in the SPMD model.
And that is how do you actually
split your data correctly?
You have to distribute your data
in a way that, you know,
doesn't increase contention on
your memory system, where each
actual processor that's assigned
the computation has
data locally to actually
operate on.
And you want to achieve an
even work distribution.
You know, do you need a dynamic
load balancing scheme
or can you use an alternative
pattern
if that's not suitable?
So the second pattern, as
opposed to the SPMD pattern is
loop parallelism pattern.
In this case, this is the best
suited when you actually have
a programming model or a program
that you can't really
change a whole lot or that
you don't really want to
change a whole lot.
Or you have a programming model
that allows you to sort
of identify loops that take up
most of the computation and
then insert annotations or some
ways to automatically
parallelize those loops.
So we saw in the OpenMP example,
you have some loops
you can insert these
pragmas that say,
this loop is parallel.
And the compiler in the run-time
time system can
automatically partition this
loop into smaller chunks.
And then each chunk can
compute in parallel.
And you might apply this scheme
in different ways
depending on how well you
understand your code.
Are you running on a shared
memory machine?
You can't afford to do a whole
lot of restructuring.
Communication costs might
be really expensive.
In the master/worker pattern,
this is really starting to get
closer to what we've
done with the Cell
recitations in the Cell labs.
You have some world of
independent tasks and the
master essentially running and
distributing each of these
tasks to different processors.
So in this case you'd get
several advantages that you
can leverage.
If each of your tasks are varied
in nature -- and they
might finish at different
times or they require
different kinds of resources,
you can use this model to sort
of view your machine as sort of
a non-symmetric processor.
Not everybody is the same.
And you can use this model
really well for that.
So you can distribute these and
then you can do dynamic
load balancing.
Because as processors --
as workers finish you can ship
them more and more data.
So it has some particularly
relevant properties for
heterogeneous computations, but
it's also really good for
when you have a whole lot
of parallelism in your
application.
So something called
embarrassingly parallel
problems. So ray tracing,
molecular dynamics, a lot of
scientific applications have
these massive levels of
parallelism.
And you can use this essentially
work-queue based
mechanism that says I have all
these tasks and I'll just
dispatch them to workers
and compute.
And as I pointed out earlier,
you know, when do you define
your entire computation
to have completed?
You know, sometimes you're
computing a result until
you've reached some result.
And often you're willing to
accept a result within some
range of error.
And you might have some
more threads that
are still in flight.
Do you terminate your
computation then or not?
What are some issues with
synchronization?
If you have so many threads that
are running together, you
know, does the communication
between them to send out these
control messages say, I'm done,
start to overwhelm you?
In the fork/join pattern --
this is really not conceptually
too different in
my mind from the master/worker
model, and also very relevant
to what we've done with Cell.
The main difference might be
that you have tasks that are
dynamically created.
So in the embarrassingly
parallel case, you actually
know the world of all your
potential task that you're
going to run in parallel.
In the fork/join join model
some new computation might
come up as a result of, say,
an event-based mechanism.
So a task might be created
dynamically and then later
terminated or they
might complete.
And so new ones come
up as a result.
AUDIENCE: It almost seems like
you are forking the task in
the forking model.
And then keep assigning
tasks to that.
The fork/join model you
just keep forking at
first virtual box.
Might not be completely
matched to a number of
processor available.
fork them out.
PROFESSOR: So the process that's
equating all these
threads or that's doing all the
forking is often known as
the parent and the
tasks that are
generated are the children.
And eventually essentially the
parent can't continue or can't
resume until its children have
sort of completed or have
reached the join point.
And so those are really some of
the models that we've seen
already, in a lot of cases in
the recitations and labs for
how you run your computations.
And some of you have already
discovered these and actually
are thinking about how your
projects should be sort of
parallelized for your
actual Cell demos.
Some of the other things that
I'm just going to talk about
are communication patterns.
So two lectures ago you saw,
for example, that you have
point to point communication
or you have broadcast
communication.
So in point to point
communication, you have two
tasks that need to
communicate.
And they can send explicit
messages to each other.
These could be control messages
that say I'm done or
I'm waiting for data.
Or they could be data messages
that actually ships you a
particular data element
that you might need.
And again we've seen
this with Cell.
Broadcast says, you know,
I have some result that
everybody needs.
And so I send that out to
everybody by some mechanism.
There is no real broadcast
mechanism on Cell.
The concept I'm going to talk
about though is the reduction
mechanism, which really is the
inverse of the broadcast. So
in the broadcast I have a data
element I need to send to
everybody else.
In the reduction, all of you
have data that I need or all
of us have data that each
somebody else needs.
So what we need to do is
collectively bring that data
together or group it together
and generate an end result.
So a simple example of a
reduction, you have some array
of elements that you want
to add together.
And sort of the result
of the collective
operation is the end sum.
So you have an array of four
elements, A0, A1, A2, and A3.
And you can do a serial
reduction.
I can take A0 and
add it to A1.
And that gives me a result.
And I can take A2 and
add that to it.
And I can take A3 and
And so at the end I'll have
sort of calculated the sum
from A0 to A3.
So this is essentially -- the
serial reduction applies when
your operation is
an associative.
So the addition is
associative.
So in this case I can actually
do something more intelligent.
And I think we talked about
that last time.
I'm going to show you
some more examples.
And often sort of the end result
follows a broadcast. It
says, here is the end result.
Who are all the people
that need it?
I'll sort of broadcast
that out so that
everybody has the result.
If your operation isn't
associative, then you're
essentially limited to
a serial process.
And so that's not very good from
a performance standpoint.
Some of the tricks you can apply
for actually getting
performance out of your
reduction is to go to a
tree-based reduction model.
So this might be very obvious.
Rather than doing A0 and A1
and then adding A2 to that
result, I can do A0
and A1 together.
In parallel I can
do A2 and A3.
And then I can get those results
and add them together.
So rather than doing n steps
I can do log n steps.
So this is particularly
attractive when only one task
needs the result.
So in the MPI program when we're
doing the integration to
calculate pi, you know, one
processor needs to print out
that value of pi.
But if you have a computation
where more than one process
actually needs the result of
the reduction, there's
actually a better mechanism you
can use that's sort of a
better alternative to the
tree-based reduction followed
by a broadcast. So you can do a
recursive doubling reduction.
So at the end here, every
process will have the result
of the reduction without having
done the broadcast. So
we can start off as with the
tree-based and add up A0 and
A1 together.
But what we do is for each
process that has a value, we
sort of do a local exchange.
So from here we communicate
the value to here.
And from here we communicate
And so now these two processors
that had the value
independently now both have
a local sum, A0 to A1.
And similarly we can sort of
make the similar symmetric
computation on the other side.
And now we can communicate data
from these two processors
here to come up with
the end --
PROFESSOR: It was there.
All right.
Must have been lost
in the animation.
So you actually do that the
other way as well so that you
have the sum A0 to A3 on all
the different processors.
Sorry about the lost
animation.
OK.
So this is better than the
tree-based approach with a
broadcast because you
end up with local
results of your reduction.
And rather than doing the
broadcast following the
tree-based reduction which takes
n steps, you end up with
an order n.
Everybody has a result in order
n versus an order 2n
process for the tree-based
plus broadcast.
AUDIENCE: On the Cell processor
but not in general.
PROFESSOR: Not in general.
It depends on sort of the
architectural mechanism that
you have for your network.
If you actually do need to sort
of, you know, if you have
a broadcast mechanism that has
bus-based architecture where
you can deposit a local value,
everybody can pull that value,
then, yeah, it can be
more efficient.
Or on optical networks, you
can broadcast the data and
everybody can just
fuse it out.
OK.
So summarizing all the different
patterns, so here
these are the actual mechanisms
that you would use
for how you would implement
the different patterns.
So in the SPMD you would
write the same program.
In loop parallelism you have
your program and you might
annotate sort of some pragmas
that tell you how to
parallelize your computation.
In the master/worker model you
might have sort of a master
that's going to create threads
and you actually know --
you might sort of have a very
good idea of what is the kind
of work you're going to have
to do in each thread.
In the fork/join model you
have more dynamism.
So you might create threads
on the fly.
And you apply these sort of
based on appeal or what is
more suited in terms of
implementation to each of the
different patterns for how you
actually organize your data.
So in the task parallelism
model, this is where you have
a world of threads that you know
you're going to calculate
or that you're going to use
for your computation.
And really you can use largely
any one of these models.
So I used a ranking
system where four
stars is really good.
One star is sort of bad or no
star means not well suited.
AUDIENCE: Sort of in
Cell because the
inherit master there.
Sometimes master/worker might
get a little bit of a biasing
than this one.
PROFESSOR: Right, so --
AUDIENCE: You don't have to pay
a cost of having master
PROFESSOR: Right.
Right.
Although you could use the
Cell master to do regular
computations as well.
But, yes.
So and the divide and conquer
model, you know, might be
especially well suited for a
fork and join because you're
creating all these recursive
subproblems They might be
heterogeneous.
In the nature of the computation
that you do, you
might have more problems
created dynamically.
Fork/join really works
well for that.
And the fact, you know, the
subproblem structure that I
showed, the graph of
sort of division.
And then merging works really
well with the fork/join model.
In the recursive, in the
geometric decomposition --
this is essentially your lab one
exercise and the things we
went over yesterday
in the recitation.
You're taking data and you're
partitioning over multiple
processors to actually
compute in parallel.
So this could be SPMD
implementation or it could be
a loop parallelism
implementation,
which we didn't do.
Less suitable, the master/worker
and fork/join,
often because the geometric
decomposition applied some
distribution to the data which
has static properties that you
can exploit in various ways.
So you don't need to
pay the overhead of
master/worker or fork/join.
Recursive data structures sort
of have very specific models
that you can run with.
Largely master/worker is a
decent implementation choice.
SPMD is another.
And you're going to hear more
about sort of the pipeline
mechanism in the next talk so
I'm not going to talk about
that very much.
Event-based coordination,
largely dynamic.
So fork/join works
really well.
So one --
AUDIENCE: When you're buffering
them you could do
master/worker with pipelining?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so next slide.
So sort of these choices or
these tradeoffs aren't really
orthogonal.
You can actually combine
them in different ways.
And in a lot of applications
what you might find is that
the different patterns compose
hierarchically.
And you actually want that
in various ways --
for various reasons.
So in the MPEG example, you
know, we had tasks here within
each task and identified
some pipeline stages.
You know, here I have some
data parallelism so I can
apply the loop pattern here.
And what I want to do is
actually in my computation
sort of express these different
mechanisms so I can
understand sort of different
tradeoffs.
And for really large
applications, there might be
different patterns that are
well suited for the actual
computation that I'm doing.
So I can combine things like
pipelining with a task-based
mechanism or data parallelism
to actually get really good
performance speedups.
And one of the things that
might strike you as well,
heck, this is a whole lot of
work that I have to do to
actually get my code in the
right way so that I can
actually take advantage of
my parallel architecture.
You know, I have to conceptually
think about the
question the right way.
I have to maybe restructure my
computation in different ways
to actually exploit
parallelism.
Data distribution
is really hard.
I have to get that right.
Synchronization issues
might be a problem.
And how much buffering
do I need to do
between different tasks?
So the thing you're going to
hear about in the next talk
is, well, what if these things
really fall out naturally from
the way you actually write the
program, and if the way you
actually write your program
matches really well with the
intuitive, sort of natural
conceptualization of the problem.
And so I'll leave Bill
to talk about that.
And I'm going to stop here.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: We can take in
some questions and
then everybody --
AUDIENCE: You talked about
fork and join.
When you have a parent thread
that spawns off to a child
thread, how do you keep your
parent thread from
using up the SPE?
PROFESSOR: So you have a
fork/join where you have --
AUDIENCE: Most of the parents
it might be the PPE.
And so if you just do fork/join,
might not really
use PPE unless you can, you
know, you have some time and
you let it do some of the
task and come back.
AUDIENCE: So for our purposes
we shouldn't spawn off new
threads by the SPEs?
PROFESSOR: So, yeah.
So most of the threads
that are spawned off
are done by the PPE.
So you have these --
in fact a good walk through
in recitation yesterday.
You have the PPE.
Essentially it sends messages to
the SPEs that says, create
these threads and start
running them.
Here's the data for them.
And then these threads
run on the SPEs.
And they just do local
computation.
And then they send messages
back to the PPE that says,
we're done.
So that essentially implements
the join mechanism.
AUDIENCE: On the other hand,
if you are doing something
like master slave way, and
then the SPE can send a
message and deliver another
job into the PPE
who feeds the master.
If SPE see there's some more
computers, you can say, OK,
look, put this into your keybord
and keep sending
messages and so the master can
look at that and update it.
So, you know, it's not only
master who has to fork off but
the slaves also.
They still can send
information back.
So you can think about
something like very
confident that way.
There are eight -- like if six
SPE is running and you first
get something in there and SPE
says divide it will take one
task and run that until the
other one to the master will
finish it and here's my ID.
Send me the message
when it's done.
And so you fork that
end and wait.
So you can assume you can
do something like that.
So it's almost master/slave but
the coordination is there.
The trouble with normally
fork/join is if you create too
many threads.
You are in like a thread hell
because there are too many
things to run.
I don't know, can you SPE?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: So you can't even do
that because of some physical
limitation.
You can't get take up 1000
threads you run another
master/slave thing yourself
is because 1000 threads
on top of your SPEs.
And that's going to
be locked threads.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Contact switching on the
SPEs is very expensive.
So on the PlayStation
3 you have six SPEs
available to you.
So if you have a lot more than
six threads that you've
created, essentially each
one runs to completion.
And then you swap that out and
you bring in -- well, that
terminates.
You deallocate it from the SPE
and you bring in a new thread.
If you actually want to do more
thread-like dynamic load
balancing on the SPEs, it's
not well suited for that.
Just because the --
AUDIENCE: The best model there
is master/slave. Because the
PPE [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
the master part.
It will run more sequential
code.
And when there's parallel send
-- it will give it to you and
produce the work queue model
type and send stuff into SPE
and feed that.
So work queue type models
can be used there.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And the SPMD model might not
work really well because you
have this heterogeneity in the
actual hardware, right.
So if I'm taking the same
program running on the SPE
versus the PPE, that code
might not be -- so I
essentially have to specialize
the code.
And that starts to deviate
away from the SPMD model.
AUDIENCE: Something I think most
of the code you write for
Cell will probably
be master/worker.
And if you try to do something
other than you should think
hard why that's the case.
PROFESSOR: You can
do fork/join but
you know, it's --
AUDIENCE: I mean you can't --
because you don't have
virtualization.
If you fork too much where are
you going to put those?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Sometimes you fork --
AUDIENCE: Yeah. but in that
sense you -- should
you fork too much?
To keep work you want
the master.
You can fork things --
you can do virtual fork and send
the work to the master
and say, here, I forked
something.
Here's the work.
I mean, the key thing is
do the simplest thing.
I mean, you guys have
two weeks left.
And if you try doing anything
complicated, you might end up
with a big mess that's
undebuggable.
Just do simple things.
And I can vouch, parallelism
is hard.
Debugging parallel code
is even harder.
So you're sort of trying to
push the limits on the
complexity of messages going
all over the world and the
three different types of
parallelism all trying to
compete in there.
Just do the simple thing.
Just get the simple
thing working.
First get the sequential code
working and keep adding more
and more story.
And then make sure that
each level it works.
The problem with parallelism
is because things that
determine if some bugs
that might show up.
Data might be hard.
But design absolutely matters.
Another thing I think,
especially for doing demos and
stuff would be nice, would be to
have a knob that basically
you can tune.
So you can say, OK, no SPEs.
Everything running in
PPE one is two is.
So you can actually see
hopefully in your code how how
things move for the demo part.
PROFESSOR: You had a question?
All right.
We'll take a brief
break and do the
quizzes in the meantime.